el dps monsters de people and earth run
for world water world never gardel
walker
el pasado 15 de febrero el presidente de
los eeuu donald trump decretó el estado
de emergencia nacional en francés
lo ha hecho contra la recomendación de
sus propios abogados con la oposición de
buena parte de los cargos políticos
republicanos y la práctica totalidad de
los demócratas
[Aplausos]
según el propio presidente ha tomado
esta decisión para lograr llevar a cabo
lo que el congreso le impedía construir
el polémico muro en la frontera con
méxico según el presidente de los eeuu
están sufriendo una auténtica invasión
de drogas inmigrantes y criminales que
ponen en riesgo la mismísima seguridad
nacional
barry james bond ahora gracias a esta
medida según miguel bein y jefe de
gabinete del presidente la
administración contará con cerca de 8
mil millones de dólares para cerrar a
cal y canto la frontera con mexico
un momento amigos porque esto es
importante cuando pusimos en marcha este
proyecto visual político nos propusimos
crear un canal donde poder contaros las
cosas que ocurrían en el mundo de una
forma libre e independiente teniendo
siempre los datos y la información
disponible como referencia y amigos y
eso es precisamente lo que tratamos de
hacer cada día te guste o no te guste
donald trump seas más o menos partidario
de la inmigración lo que os vamos a
contar en este vídeo es lo que nos dice
la última información disponible
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hace poco más de dos años que donald
trump llegó a la casa blanca con una
promesa que destacaba por encima del
resto construir un enorme muro a lo
largo de toda la frontera con méxico
google+ world of nations wind blows jon
un muro de casi 2.000 millas más de 3000
kilómetros de longitud para que os
hagáis una idea de lo que esto significa
podemos echar un vistazo a lo que este
proyecto puede terminar costando fijaos
teniendo en cuenta que hay casi 1000
kilómetros de muros y vallas ya
construidos terminarlo en su totalidad
tal y como se propone trump es decir con
al menos nueve metros de altura y
barreras que dificulten la construcción
de túneles costaría según las mejores
estimaciones más de 30 mil millones de
dólares el propio departamento de
seguridad nacional ha cifrado en más de
20 mil millones el coste de completar el
cierre de la frontera si se opta por
algo más modesto y se alternan según los
tramos el muro con vallas 20 mil
millones de dólares
y ojo hablamos tan solo del coste de
construcción porque ya os adelanto que
el mantenimiento de una infraestructura
de este tipo no es algo precisamente
barato ahora bien antes de que invitase
vuestro veredicto hay unas cuantas
preguntas que creo debemos responder
porque este muro ha sido tan polémico
porque oponerse a un muro que digamos en
principio tiene como fin ordenar la
frontera hacer que se cumpla la ley y
disuadir a muchas personas a embarcarse
en un viaje que les puede costar la vida
acaso trump no tiene razón al decir que
con este muro eeuu sería un país más
seguro atentos
[Música]
el muro historia y consecuencias
inesperadas no lo cierto es que no la
propuesta de donald trump no es
exactamente algo nuevo toda esta
historia de cerrar la frontera con
méxico comenzó ya en 1986 cuando ronald
reagan construyó en san diego 22
kilómetros de valla de acero eso sí a
cambio de legalizar a 3 millones de
inmigrantes ilegales con el que ha sido
el mayor programa de regularización de
la historia de los eeuu
poder
by por el fdt hispanos honran a nancy
reagan y agradecen la amnistía firmada
por su esposo ronald en el 86 sí creo
que podemos decir que eran otros tiempos
en el partido republicano
landis gran poder aun subir sweeting
crisis civil y coventry en donde es
country because they de an
[Música]
y por dos
showtime de mayor relieve
el caso es que para el año 2000 la
longitud de la frontera fortificada con
un oso con bayas apenas había crecido
hasta las 60 millas unos 100 kilómetros
casi todo en zonas urbanas
[Música]
josh spence de inicios perfecto
pero en toda esta historia el año 2006
fue un punto y aparte a cambio de una
ley para regularizar a casi todos los
inmigrantes ilegales una ley que al
final no se aprobó george bush aceptó
construir una valla a lo largo de casi
700 millas de las cuales a día de hoy se
han construido la mayor parte
la cuestión es que estas barreras han
tenido consecuencias que creo os van a
sorprender
veréis hasta la década de los 90 las
personas más o menos podían circular
libremente a través de la frontera de
tal forma que muchos trabajadores
procedentes fundamentalmente de mexico
la cruzaban una y otra vez por ejemplo
la cruzaban para trabajar en el campo
durante el verano y luego regresar a sus
casas durante el invierno de esta forma
aunque era muchas más las personas que
cruzaban irregularmente la frontera el
número de inmigrantes ilegales viviendo
en eeuu se mantenía más o menos estable
en torno a los 3 millones de personas
sin embargo a medida que aumentaron los
kilómetros de vallas muros y controles
fronterizos el coste de cruzar la
frontera se disparó tan solo entre el
año 1995 y el año 2009 se estima que el
coste de cruzar la frontera para un
inmigrante pasó de 500 a más de 3000
dólares es decir se multiplicó por más
de 6
todo este gigantesco incremento en el
coste de cruzar la frontera junto a los
mayores riesgos de que te detuvieran
hizo que las personas que llegaban a
eeuu a trabajar ya no se fueran
y esto es precisamente una de las cosas
que explican que a pesar de contar con
tres veces más agentes fronterizos y con
más de 600 millas de vallas y mulos el
número de inmigrantes ilegales viviendo
en los eeuu sea muchísimo mayor que la
década de los 90 80 y 70 hay más
factores pero este es importante se
puede que el muro no sea tan efectivo
como parece al fin y al cabo el
incentivo de cruzar la frontera es tan
grande que hasta ahora los muros no han
sido impedimento alguno simplemente los
mecanismos para cruzarlo se han vuelto
más caros favoreciendo incluso el efecto
contrario al que se pretendía
[Música]
pero es que además en los últimos años
se ha producido otro gran cambio hoy la
inmensa mayor parte de los inmigrantes
ilegales ya no cruzan la frontera de
forma ilegal sino que llegan legalmente
para un avión se plantan en eeuu
cuando expira el tiempo de permanencia
máximo simplemente se quedan y ahí el
muro pues no va a hacer nada
[Música]
pero amigos todo esto responde tan solo
parcialmente a las preguntas que nos
hemos hecho nos falta ver como el muro
puede afectar realmente a esa invasión
de criminales que donald trump considera
toda una emergencia nacional
[Música]
la no emergencia nacional
en la casa blanca lo tienen muy pero que
muy claro la frontera con méxico se ha
convertido en un coladero de criminales
cerrar la cal y canto' es una cuestión
de seguridad nacional
pero amigos hasta qué punto pensáis que
esto es cierto
pues vamos a ver si esto es verdad lo
normal es que se produzcan tres cosas
primero lógicamente que a través de la
frontera lleguen muchos criminales
segundo que la propia frontera sea un
lugar peligroso por ejemplo para las
personas que trabajan en la guardia
fronteriza no vamos a ver si la frontera
está infestada de criminales y narcos
cruzándola como pedro por su casa este
trabajo tiene que ser realmente
peligroso no os parece y tercero que los
estados más perjudicados sean
precisamente los que más inmigrantes
ilegales tienen pues bien te hago una
pregunta sí sí a ti y no vale no
responder crees que estos tres puntos se
cumplen veámoslo
empecemos por la primera cuestión si la
frontera es un coladero de criminales lo
normal es que la atraviesen muchos
criminales pues según los datos del
propio gobierno de los eeuu esto no es
del todo así los inmigrantes ilegales
detenidos por las patrullas fronterizas
tienen unos historiales de criminalidad
muy reducidos y por cierto el dato cada
vez es más pequeño tan solo el 0.04 por
ciento de los inmigrantes ilegales
detenidos tenían condenas por los
delitos más graves de homicidio o
asesinato
[Música]
esto amigos es una tasa menor que la del
conjunto de los eeuu aquí lo que llegan
son básicamente familias queréis otro
dato la tasa de asesinatos de miembros
de la guardia fronteriza es decir de las
personas que están en primera línea
contra todos esos supuestos criminales
es de apenas dos personas por cada
100.000 agentes diez veces menos que la
tasa de 19,7 que tiene el resto de
cuerpos de policía en el resto del país
e incluso es menos de la mitad que la
tasa general en los eeuu
[Música]
vamos que los guardias fronterizos están
más seguros haciendo su trabajo que el
resto de ciudadanos de los eeuu
[Música]
en otras palabras si en la frontera hay
una emergencia nacional entonces en las
ciudades de eeuu no se tiene que estar
viviendo toda una guerra campal pero ya
sé lo que alguno está pensando enrique
esto es porque los criminales son muy
listos y la patrulla fronteriza no los
detiene bueno pues en ese caso veamos
qué ocurre con las tasas de delincuencia
y criminalidad en los territorios
aledaños de la frontera que serán los
primeros donde actúen todos estos
criminales no pues amigos la tasa de
criminalidad en los 23 condados que hay
a lo largo de la frontera con méxico
está por debajo de la del resto de
condados que no están en la frontera con
méxico
[Música]
en texas la tasa de condenas criminales
de inmigrantes ilegales es casi la mitad
la mitad que la que se da entre la
población nativa
[Música]
y por último amigos el tercer punto será
cierto que los estados más peligrosos de
eeuu son los que más inmigrantes
ilegales tienen porque estos son más
propensos a cometer crímenes pues no
tampoco de hecho todo lo contrario
como los inmigrantes ilegales son menos
propensos a cometer crímenes que la
población nativa y los inmigrantes
legales lo son aún menos por cierto
ocurre que en los estados cuanto más
porcentaje de la población está formada
por inmigrantes ilegales más seguros son
estos
amigos podemos discutir si la
inmigración tiene efectos positivos o
negativos sobre la economía es algo de
lo que ya hemos hablado aquí en visual
político pero en eeuu no tiene un efecto
negativo sobre la criminalidad todo lo
contrario de la misma forma que el muro
tampoco va a frenar la inmigración
ilegal con lo que tirar decenas y
decenas de miles de millones en algo que
no sirve para nada pues no parece lo más
inteligente por eso muchas personas se
oponen al dichoso muro incluido muchos
muchísimos republicanos
m
en we walk away
[Música]
y will hunting con los datos en la mano
la política del muro es una política
digamos un poco chapucero por no hablar
del abuso de poder que supone que el
ejecutivo de donald trump esté tratando
de saltarse el poder del congreso y la
separación de poderes con una figura
pensada para casos de emergencia
nacional
[Aplausos]
y esto amigos evidentemente no es una
emergencia entre otras cosas porque ni
la seguridad nacional está en riesgo ni
es algo que se vaya a solucionar de
forma inmediata
en fin amigos con este vídeo hemos
querido recoger los principales datos y
ponerlos sobre la mesa para que sepamos
por qué tantas y tantas personas se
oponen al muro y ojo oponerse al muro no
implica necesariamente estar a favor de
las fronteras abiertas ni nada por el
estilo sino simplemente estar en contra
de una idea que con los datos en la mano
solo parece buena para las empresas que
van a construir el muro por cierto para
construirlo el gobierno de los eeuu
tiene que expropiar los derechos de una
enorme cantidad de territorio lo que
tampoco va mucho con la cultura
norteamericana nos parece por cierto una
última noticia antes de terminar los
próximos días 8 y 9 de marzo estaremos
el león participando en unas jornadas en
la universidad te dejamos más
información en la descripción así que si
te animas a acompañarnos genial por allí
nos veremos y ya sabéis si os ha gustado
el vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
siguiente
[Aplausos]
[Música]